desolación deja el tiroteo en texas en
rival de llorar a sus víctimas y esperan
acciones
es realmente triste que tengamos que
pasar por esto me entristece y me enoja
nuestro gobierno por no hacer más sobre
el control de armas
intenso
todo el mundo conocía a este chico
quiero decir que este barrio es tan
unidos que incluso sabían que este chico
tenía problemas mentales verdad sabían
que lo acosaban sabían que no se iba a
graduar
en washington david jou un sobreviviente
del tiroteo de parkland en 2018 quien
ahora es activista por el control de
armas espera que haya un cambio tras
este ataque tiene que ser simplemente
diferente porque creo la realidad es que
el movimiento ha estado haciendo este
trabajo durante décadas hemos estado
organizando estrategias desde antes de
patna incluso antes de sandy hook pero
él critica a los republicanos que piden
armar a los profesores como respuesta a
los tiroteos en las escuelas
creo que si miras la historia de los
países que realmente han acabado esto
ninguno de ellos lo ha hecho armando a
los profesores o convirtiendo las
escuelas en efectivamente prisiones con
guardias armados y cosas así en este
barrio de chicago en el este de illinois
predominan los latinos al igual que en
yuvald y sus habitantes ven con
preocupación lo que ocurrió en texas
creo que seguirán llegando pensamientos
y oraciones y nunca veremos ningún
cambio real parece que no importa cuánto
lo exija este país los líderes no tienen
ninguna intención de mantenernos a salvo
en el senado estadounidense los
demócratas abrieron de nuevo el debate
sobre el control de armas pero necesitan
60 votos como mínimo para que pase
cualquier proyecto y tan solo tendría en
máximo 50